myself in the mirror and accept
that
if you weren't a racist
you condone what a racist did so that's
to me the same thing it's the same thing
so
i agree with you michelle you got a big
following so well god bless you i
appreciate it
hey folks the man with the pinky ring
and the new york thing forget about it
brad bergwood and you're watching
another episode of the bad brad birkwood
show on the ringside report web tv
channel now make sure you follow me on
twitter at bad brad rsr again it's at
bad brand rsr and check out my amazing
writing team on ringsidereport.com
well today folks
i got a special guest who's a friend of
mine and a friend of my show
who i greatly appreciate all the support
as he always says about the support i
give him i appreciate all of his support
back as well he is the host of the
popular podcast the tony michaels pod
with co-host gabe sanchez who does those
fantastic tick tock videos and i had on
my show a couple weeks ago
he also is an activist
who gets out there and puts it out there
just as strong as i do and why does he
do it because like me he cares about
humanity and he wants to keep
moving humanity forward
so without further ado
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
my show
the one
the only
tony
michaels
all right
i got my brother from another mother on
with muhammad ali looking over us in the
back knocking sonny listing out in a
rematch that we talked about on this
show so first of all good afternoon and
welcome to the show tony thanks thanks
for having me it's a pleasure being here
on the bad brad berkwitch show and you
know what i got to give you props man
because so many people yeah wrote my
last name
and i know it's a little you know it
could be a tongue with the bbb
right right you say it but that's
because you had drama and you were
debating all that yeah that's right
you're good at doing it because dude
i've been called everything from son of
sam you know david berkowitz yeah yeah
yeah
back with the berkwitz you name it i've
been calling it so i appreciate every
time you say it you say it right burke
well you know um it's it's funny you say
that because i mess up a lot of people's
names like
and some of it's intentional like i
don't call matt i call it matt gatts
right not gates matt getz i'd be like
that's how you say it i'm like that's
exactly how i say it and the reason why
is because i figured it this way i'm
like he would be so pissed off
like not what i say but that i [ __ ] up
his name that i'm like i'm gonna say it
every time i'm gonna say it wrong that
way if he ever hears just me say his
name just once just once he happens to
hear me say his name that's right i
intentionally say it wrong so [ __ ] him
you know exactly but that's like when
people correct me and i say mike penis
like oh no they are correct i said no i
meant to say mike penis like i said on
his show because he's a dick right i'm
playing simple you know everybody always
wants to correct you so
let's just let's jump right into this
man because we've got a lot to talk
about today
so first thing i always tell everybody
like i told gabe when he came on anybody
else if i got anything wrong in my notes
don't be shy to say hey brad it's
actually this because you know the
military in me wants to be factually
correct sure okay
so it looks like from your bio
you grew up in
central missouri
a small farm town near the lake of the
ozarks just 15 minutes from the netflix
series that deb and i love and binge
watch till five o'clock in the morning
just recently
the oh uh ozark with uh jason bateman oh
that's a good show
i've got a good story about ozark too if
we get to that okay all right i'll tell
you what
well incorporated with this talk about
growing up there
kind of you know how things were maybe
how it molded you and throwing the ozark
story yeah so you know um i agree it's a
small town you know when i was growing
up it was just over 4 000 people
and it's a town near lake of the ozarks
but it's it's it's really close um it's
part of the lake because there's several
towns around the lake of the ozarks
because the lake is so big
but my grandparents owned a resort at
the lake so i i usually say i didn't
grow up at the lake i grew up in the
lake because we would go every weekend
we would swim
you know all weekend long um so i grew
up swimming in the uh the swamp that is
the lake of the ozarks but
i i did grow up on a small farm so it
was kind of like a hobby farm you know
we had we had bottle calves and chickens
and we would get up every morning and
feed and water the the chickens and
bottle feed the calves and feed the
cattle and
so we would cut wood for our stove
because that's how we heated the house
was with a wood stove so it was an old
old house that was built in the 40s
and it's just a small farm grew up you
know three or four miles outside of town
uh the closest house was about a quarter
mile away so
what you what you would think of
as you know
rule that's how i grew up right so
um
it is weird sometimes for people to see
and hear the things that i say and how i
say them
um i think it confuses some people i
think that's why
you know there's such a draw to how i
say things and
maybe my perspective on things is
because of that but a good ozark story
is when they were going to shoot that
series they wanted to shoot it at the
leg of the ozarks and actually in the
first season
there's a hotel that they shoot at that
marnie byrd and his family go to the
first hotel yeah yeah that's right so so
that
that hotel is actually at the lake of
the ozarks um and it's very close just a
stone's throw away from the bagnal dam
which is the man-made dam that made the
man-made lake that is the lake of the
ozarks
but that hotel now it's it's run down
it's abandoned um some business bought
it and didn't keep it open uh
but that is one of the only scenes
that they do that is shot at least
besides the b-roll footage that shot it
like it was almost all the rest of it is
shot in georgia and us from the lake of
the ozarks can tell because there's a
lot of pine trees at the lake of the
ozarks there's not a lot of pine it's
it's cedar or oak um at the lake of the
ozarks because it's just it's pure rock
like the ground is pure rock so you know
you don't have any soil for a really
good tree to grow so oak and cedar is
what grows not pine
so we so we from the lake of the ozarks
can look at the film and the footage and
know that it's not actually the lake the
b-roll is the lake the b-roll is the
lake but but um you know uh a funny
story about marty bird and
and jason bateman his character and
going um to film at the lake they were
gonna shoot it um
kind of a ways away from the bagel dam
originally at a uh at like a bed and
breakfast that was originally when we
first started hearing about in the area
that they were gonna shoot this this
movie or film or tv series whatever they
called it at that time with jason
bateman like that was the word he was
down
um at the bagel dam at the strip he was
walking around but they looked at this
bed and breakfast and people were so
[ __ ] pissed off in the area about how
they were gonna how they were gonna
portray them as drug dealers and
druggies and you know drug addicts and
all this stuff you know how how they
were gonna portray the lake of the
ozarks that they were throwing rocks
through the window of the bed and
breakfast um that that they were looking
to film that first season in oh wow yeah
and they end up filming it you know in
georgia because missouri doesn't get
very good tax breaks for filming georgia
does right so but but the locals were so
[ __ ] pissed off that they would you
know make them look bad or whatever that
they were actually i mean there were
stories in the paper about people
throwing rocks and leaving notes on
their doorstep and all kinds of [ __ ]
just because they were cement but then
they don't think about all the revenue
that would have brought the area if they
would have filmed there right well you
know and that's um
that's one thing that missouri failed on
uh with that series is they really could
have shot it at the lake of the ozarks
it would have made it more authentic
there's plenty of places to shoot
at the lake um even like i mean there's
strip clubs and everything else like the
first season
so there's plenty of places at the lake
that they could have shot this stuff um
but they but they ultimately didn't and
not because they weren't exactly welcome
in the area i don't think that bothered
me as much it was the the amount of
money the you know the revenue that they
have
for the tax breaks that missouri
wouldn't give so ultimately they didn't
shoot it there um but uh parts of it
parts of it are shot there and a lot of
b-roll footage shot there but uh i set
the lake no it's not but it um as far as
like the
everyone wants to ask like how close is
it is it really that close i'm like well
it's not far off in some aspects some
aspects you know obviously it's complete
fantasy but um but yeah there's some
aspects about the lake that are very
mysterious um and cloaked with
uh a lot of uh
mystery in that way just because
it is easy to hide things in a place
okay
okay now you told me you got and i want
to tell the viewers that for younger
viewers because they probably won't know
but you got a mel
carnahan story and let me read this for
the viewers because i remember this
story very well for the viewers
uh carnahan died in a plane crash while
running the u.s senate race in missouri
and the state still voted for him
even though he was dead over incumbent
john ashcroft that's correct right tony
okay and who would later become and i
remember the attorney general in uh
george w bush's admin
administration so talk about some tell
the viewers the mel carnahan story you
have so yeah so my mom worked at the uh
for the state government of missouri um
and she worked she wasn't she didn't
work for
a governor specifically um she worked
for all of them she was a bureaucrat so
she worked in the office of
administration and
part of the budget and planning office
now mel carnahan was quite the character
um at the time that he died he was
actually the governor of the state of
missouri he was the sitting governor
running for the u.s senate against john
ashcroft who was the previous governor
of the state of missouri um and john
ashcroft and mel carnahan had had a
history you know of of of competing
against each other in races or being in
politics together for for many many
decades um we all know john ashcroft was
the the famous
attorney general during 9 11 and the
bush administration you know that's kind
of how the country knows him but
we knew him we knew him as the incumbent
u.s senator so here was a governor who
wasn't that popular especially with
conservatives in the state
because he had vetoed an abortion bill
that would have banned abortion
um and that's kind of what made him
unpopular because mel carnahan wasn't
like this like liberal you know he was
he's kind of a missouri democrat in
other words uh kind of like jay nixon if
anyone's familiar with modern politics
he's more
more conservative not really
you know they say rhino you might say
dino like democrat name only in some
sense
but mel carnahan had a lot of empathy
and that's what really drew people to
mel carnahan i mean when my mom would
say that uh like when she would go watch
the phones in the governor's office
sometimes to fill in
for the ladies that would watch the
phones when mel would walk by like the
governor would just be walking by and he
would actually say your name he'd know
your name he would know who you were
a lot of governors don't do that but he
did and what he would do because they
got to know the carnahans from the from
the time that he was governor because
they would actually have their budget
office because the budget office did a
lot of work every year to balance the
missouri budget he would invite those
bureaucrats not the politicians not the
not the appointed officials but the
bureaucrats the actual people who work
for the state he would invite him to the
governor's mansion and and feed them a
meal and thank them for all the hard
work that they did on the budget and so
that's kind of how my mom got to know
mel gronahan
and the night that he
died in a plane crash my grandmother
worked at a factory in our small town
and she worked second shift and on her
way home she heard
that he had died in a plane crash on the
radio and so she called my mom
and i woke up because i was sleeping it
was in the middle of the night and um i
woke up to my mom screaming and
hollering because
she had found out that mel carnahan had
died in a plane crash and
we actually
one of the most distinct unique
experiences that i have with american
politics and state politics and politics
in general is mel carnahan's funeral
because my mom pulled me and my brother
out of school to go because she knew it
would be a historic event because they
kind of they shut down the city they
shut down the state capitol because bill
clinton and al gore the president vice
president at the time
were going to come to the capitol and
the united states senators the state
senators the united states congressmen i
mean they were all there in one spot
what year was that tony what year was
that that was the year 2000 the end of
2000 which is really weird like when i
was when i was looking at this when i
did the bio for you i was like man this
is really weird because
it feels like to me
when i stood there because i stood at a
rail and watched the current vice
president at the time um bill clinton
and hillary clinton and then al gore and
tip gore they were walking together side
by side which is very
very rare that you see them you know
somewhere away from dc in a setting like
that
because of security and everything else
to see them together but not only that
you had all the united states senators
the congressmen walking behind them
um to honor mel carnahan
and it was just it was so it was uh
it sticks out in my mind so much that
everyone was there for him and in a time
like this
like we wouldn't but the thing that
really got me last night when i was
looking at it was that
just just one year later 911 happened
because you got to remember the uh after
mel carnahan died
just weeks after he he died they had the
the election the the 2020 election and
we all know how the presidential
election kind of did but mel carnahan
beat john ashcroft a dead guy a dead
dude
beat the incumbent republican united
states senator in the state of missouri
who was a former governor who went on to
be the attorney general his son his
bigoted ass son is now our secretary of
state and it just
it
in that time and in that moment when he
actually died roger wilson the
lieutenant governor became the governor
he was a democrat as well
um he appointed uh mel's wife gene uh
temporarily and remember this yep yeah
and then and then they had a special
election and uh gene ended up losing in
the special election but
but the point of the story i guess to me
is that's probably really where my
interest
in american politics on politics in
general but american politics
happened because i seen the brute force
of what it was like
for the american political machine
regardless of party to walk
and to honor
um a governor and
what would have been a united states
sitting senator so it was um it was very
unique to my experience because i never
experienced anything like that before i
mean i i mean i'd never really been that
close to quote unquote a famous person
and here they all are like every one of
them are are quote unquote you know
known people especially at the time the
president which we all know what bill
clinton and hillary clinton were going
through and al gore who was running for
president was standing right there right
within feet of me walking to honor mel
carnegie so it was um but you know what
tony and that and that's a very touching
story i'm glad you told the viewers that
story but isn't it disgusting that we
fast forward 21 years to this day and
you just said something
all the centers all these people were
there regardless of party that [ __ ]
wouldn't happen today for nobody they
didn't oh yeah so absolutely and because
and because of trump trump in a way that
he handled himself and all of his flak
is uh flunkies behind him ted cruz look
how they acted when when uh uh
supreme court uh supreme court justice
kbj just got uh you know when they did
the ceremony and they walked out ted
cruz and all those [ __ ] pricks and
how disrespectful they were like you
just said
only two decades ago not like centuries
ago three [ __ ] decades ago
we had some type of decorum well it was
difficult it was [ __ ] dignity exactly
because it wouldn't happen today
right because that's what they were
doing was it was honoring yeah
his humanity yes his dignity i mean uh
you know you always you always say uh
humanity right i mean that's that's
really our dignity in this country is
what
it's what anyone's asking for and you
know um a lot of people you know talk
about my cussing or the way that i say
things um because i really railed on
even mitt romney for clapping like we
shouldn't i mean yes yes we should give
him credit but at the same time is the
bar really to honor the first black
woman to be confirmed as a united states
supreme court justice standing and
clapping is that the bar is that really
the [ __ ] bar that we no it's
disgusting i i i understand your logic
to where you're going with that
but with you know i'm i know we
celebrate by you know applauding you
know when i got in the hall of fame they
applauded me i i definitely understand
your logic because the bar is so low but
they did that with trump if trump would
do something that was remotely
on par what he was supposed to do we
gave him credit because he's
presidential he's president
but yet they forgot remember this one
the viewers are probably remember when
he was at the podium because he did so
much i can be presidential when he
starts going like a robot because oh he
doesn't have to be playful quick but i'm
glad that you told that story because it
proves the point that the the um the
decorum the civility that we had at one
time even when senator mccain died when
the flag was at half mass he had it
brought back up and then he had to be
told you have to bring it back down how
he talked about a man that was a warrior
i don't care if they didn't agree on
politics forget i don't care about that
but to talk about him in death we've
never seen that before and what you said
i'm glad that you told that story so it
shows the younger generation that
because
sometimes the left the younger
uh
part of the left would be like well you
know brad you you say reaganist but he
did this he did i said i did i'm not
arguing policies i'm just telling you
that there was some type of decorum in
politics in the past that's the biggest
point i try to make well and that's
that's the argument that i make a lot is
that the two parties aren't the same you
know a lot of that [ __ ] goes around
like all the two parties are the same
and like no they're not no they're not
because because the democrats the
democrats would have decency they would
have empathy they would use their
dignity and give respect to someone who
who deserved that humanity but the other
the other party does not no that's
because they're not a political party
anymore they're a cult it's a fascist
movement and that's and and they're
they're hell-bent on the destruction of
our democracy and when i say ours i mean
ours we the people yeah i mean that's
the only way that we we i mean that's
the only way that we secure liberty in
this country that's right
all right i want to give a little show a
little spoiler because we're going to go
into your tick tock videos but i want to
tell the people a little bit of
something about your tick tock videos
yeah so in high school
i found out
tony's bio that he was in debate class
he took drama and i think you did speech
too right you did speech yeah yeah yeah
i did i did almost every play and i was
in drama and i did speech and debate
competitions as well so
even though his videos are fire
he has you know i did some acting a
little while so i bring a little bit of
that stick to my show you know
especially these new videos that i'm
doing but
it ties in so i was aware of tony before
we met last year because debbie said you
got to see this video this guy
so she sends me the video and then
[ __ ] him you know i was like i was dying
because tony walks so he's walking and
talking in the video and tick tock
videos at least when i stop richie so i
remember what it was a while back it was
one that like kind of went viral so
she shows this video i'm like this guy's
hilarious so i saw from time to time i
would see on twitter and i used to be on
facebook i'm completely off of facebook
but your videos would show up people
would share these things and they were
hilarious so what i want to ask you is
about the tick tock videos
what was like the deciding factor or
you know what i i just okay this is a
bridge too far i got a vent and this is
going to be my medium to do it because
they blew up after you started them
maybe not right away but they eventually
they blew up well
you know the pandemic happened and i i
discovered this app called tic tac which
i think a lot of people discovered
during the pandemic you know we were all
sitting our houses trying to figure out
how not to be [ __ ] bored so um i
downloaded tic tac and i did all the
dance videos and they're still all there
if you want to go down the feed there's
a lot of videos but
you can find all this all the stupid
dancing videos all the stupid shits
there that that you first yeah that you
first yeah did you first do when you
when you stick you know you're trying to
figure out what the hell it is and
that's the first thing they want you to
do all these things but i put it down
for the summer
and um
after the election of course i watched
you know i paid attention on twitter
and i had
i i you know just pay attention to the
news because politics interest me uh in
general
and i've always been you know on the
democratic side i guess the liberal
commie socialist radical you know
left-leaning right right but um when i
when i watched um
after the election happened and joe
biden completely [ __ ] spanked uh
donald trump in the election
by almost eight million votes and not
only would he not concede because i knew
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] wouldn't
concede right i knew he wouldn't say i
lost
but
when he started it was evident in late
november early december when he really
when he really was making it obvious
that he was going to try to remain in
power because that's the way i felt is
that this guy is gonna try not now as
delusional as it was he really thinks
he's gonna remain in power
and
i couldn't take it anymore
so i just started
talking into the tick tock
and the one video that went viral it
it's uh it's called snowflake fascist um
is the the original title of the video
and if you go to my tik tok account i've
got a version of it pinned to the top of
the page
because it's probably my
i guess most viral everyone likes that
video and it's still relevant it'll
probably be relevant for a long time
but i almost didn't make that video i
was making a few videos that day i was
finishing up my walk i'm like you know i
want to say something i want to say this
and i made that video and that's really
what blew up my
tick tock account and people wanted me
to keep doing political commentary so i
kept doing it in november and really
into december
and then people kept saying we want to
hear more like we like how you say
things you say it differently you have a
different tone you know you don't you
look like you know this is all in the
comments they say you look like a
trumper but you don't talk like one or
you sound like a trumper and you don't
talk like one and you know and um
i i started to catch on that maybe maybe
a longer form type of content would be
relevant
and i'm really good at long content form
because i i just don't stop talking my
audience knows that um there's very few
dead pauses in my show and i do two
hours every single day so
i have a lot to say about it and i feel
like
with my background not just uh
communicating when i was you know
practicing drama or speech and debate
but i've been in sales you know
belly-to-belly with human beings my
whole life so communication has always
been my career so
um i felt like maybe i could communicate
on that level
so the tick tock account kind of turned
into
the podcast which um as everyone knows
it's now evolved into a two-hour show
every single day yep i'm gonna get it
i'm gonna get into i'm gonna segue into
that
um
how long are you gonna go back and do
any i think i've been asked this
question too about you are you gonna go
back to be doing uh some tick tock here
and there so so i'm hope i'm hoping to
you know i put videos up on tick tock
now um but they're not the walking rants
that they used to do um now that the
weather is getting nicer here i may i
may get it back out and do some more
walking rants they may not be the same
maybe they will be you know i don't know
um
it uh the two-hour show takes up a lot
of time with prep and
and then doing the show and then post
post doing the show you know getting
everything downloaded and uploaded and
cutting clips and so it's a lot of work
but um but hopefully i can get back to
at least posting a couple uh walking
rants a week um maybe walking talks or
something like that
but i i i think we could get back to uh
to some of those uh
very very very um
cursing uh [ __ ] rants i used to when
i used to when i used to do the rants i
would
i would like go back and i would count
how many [ __ ] i said
in each rant and i think my record in 60
second rant i think was 22 [ __ ] i think
is how many how many i got it
yeah you get compared to what's the
guy's name because uh deb
sees him more than me in the videos
who's the other is it the liberal
redneck is that his name uh trey crowder
is uh one guy yeah tree crowder does um
he does kind of like a car rant yeah um
and then um corey uh forrester the
buttercream dream as he's sometimes
known he he does he does content too he
does some walking type rants or
but they're more you know they're more
comedians right right i don't really i
mean as much as i try to be funny uh and
i think you know naturally but you're
naturally tony it comes across right
right but i i don't i'm not telling
jokes personally right i'm not writing
jokes i mean i mean maybe
maybe in some sense but i i see myself
and view myself more as a political
commentator now now that i've been doing
it for a while uh maybe at one time i
thought well you know because i've done
some stand-up before now unsuccessfully
successfully you know just as like open
mic but
but i mean i guess i guess i've never
really viewed myself when i was doing
this content as a comedian more as a
commentator whereas i think trey and um
corey to their credit they're
funny-ass comedians i mean they're
hilarious uh brent tarion too is oh yeah
yeah
yeah he's hilarious um to their credit
they're they're great comedians i'm
probably not near as good a comedian as
they are um that that make political
statements which they should in their
comedy i i view myself more now um
where i'm at is is a commentator more
than a comedian so okay i want to read
something we're going to talk about the
show
so for the viewers if you don't know and
you should know if you follow me
tony hosts the tony michael's pod and he
with co-host uh gabe sanchez who i had
on about two weeks ago on my show who
does the hilarious gabe does the one of
the best tick tock videos there is out
there so check out gabe as well but i
want to read something about the show
and again i told you before but
congratulations because folks if you
didn't know tony's on the midas touch um
network now which is a big deal so he's
got an even bigger audience which is
great
but you described
um
you said you modeled your political talk
show or podcast
um
basically off of right wing rush limbo
sean heady that style but you do it
from the complete left of what they're
doing right what i found interesting was
where you said um
you believe you believe the your
approach
no no well i'm getting ahead of myself
here you know what happened i cut
something out that i wanted
you explained
why you think
the democrats need to do it the way
that you're doing it
from the left a rush limbo version but
from the left so explain
to the viewers
your talk about the show but explain to
you them why you think the democrats
should be doing
that format
so um
not to wind back too far but when i was
in my sales career i would spend a lot
of time in the car and because i was so
interested in politics i'd want to
listen to politics on the radio well
in this country the only place to listen
to politics on the radio is
right-wingers that's it there's a
left-wing talk radio out there none of
it and and the reason why is because
democrats are so scared of their shadow
like right there they're scared of being
wrong they're scared of getting a fact
wrong here they're scared of being you
know too broad and broad strokes and
painting things with broad strokes
they're scared of of using simple
language and not having statistics and
well the reason why the right wing is so
prevalent in our country and the reason
why we're in the situation that we're in
with this with the cheeto dust mobster
and we're running around trying to
figure out how in the [ __ ] are we going
to make sure that we prosecute this
[ __ ] idiot so he gets held
accountable for the crimes he's
committed the reason why we're in this
situation
is because the country has been
absolutely [ __ ] inundated with right
wing talk style radio rather it be the
wrestling ball show sean hannity glenn
beck mark levin
michael savage
if you go down the list of local you got
your local [ __ ] commentators that
absolutely pound the airwaves every
single morning
that aren't necessarily syndicated but
they're they're a huge influence in
those local politics and then they turn
on the [ __ ] news at night to fox news
away in a news max and all the while in
between they're looking at facebook and
we're standing around wondering why in
the [ __ ] does half of our country
believe a bunch of nonsense and [ __ ]
it's because they're being fed and
they've been fed it for three well
really four goddamn decades
so
uh of course i would vehemently disagree
with almost every [ __ ] word that left
rush limbaugh or sean hannity's mouth i
mean brad if you can imagine my rants
i'm i'm yelling and screaming at the
radio as i'm driving i'm sure some
people saw and they're like this dude's
a [ __ ] maniac
he's driving and he's yelling at someone
but there's no one in the car right
but
i saw something and felt something that
i think the left wing misses in this
country
because the left wing and democrats um
they're always painted up as elites
because they kind of want to be that
right they want to be smarter they want
to have more facts they want to have it
right they want to be correct well
you're not always correct you're not
always right you don't have always have
all the facts but there is one thing
that you [ __ ] can do
as imperfect as we are we can stand for
equality we can stand for equity we can
stand we can stand for liberty we can
stand for decency dignity and humanity
you can do those things
and you can do those things in the style
that they do on the right wing um i
think that's one thing that i bring to
the table is that unique um that unique
style and i think it's not only because
of
you know where i'm from because i i did
grow up in rural missouri but also
also the years and years that i listened
to them and i know their cadence i know
the language that they use
very rarely when you come watch our show
if you do come watch our show will you
have me tread out just a list of facts
and make you feel stupid and make me
feel so much more educated than you let
me tell you something bread rush limb
ball is a college dropout
from the rule part
state of missouri
okay
i'm a two-time i'm a two-time college
dropout
from the rural part of missouri
now
i am not rush limbaugh because i am not
going to use my talent whatever that may
be
and what i can and can't do for [ __ ]
despicable evil vile fascist things um i
like you want to have people all people
it doesn't matter your religion
your color your skin where you come from
what you sound like your sexuality your
gender whatever the [ __ ] it is
i think all people deserve dignity
humanity and most of all in this country
you are afforded the right to liberty
and i believe that that comes before
anything else and so i if i can use what
i have as imperfect as
um everyone may be but i may be if i can
just use that one thing to try to
get people to understand that
that rule people
rule people they they want universal
health care
they want they want a minimum wage
really high
they they want college to be really
affordable almost free like they want
those things but democrats have a stupid
way of saying these things they say
universal health care and we want we
want free college and and
and the thing is if you just got down to
the bear facts
and the bear agenda and you said
americans americans don't want to go
bankrupt because of a medical bill
americans don't want to be saddled to
college debt until they're retired
like if you go to college with college
debt and you pay off it takes your whole
[ __ ] career to pay it off what good
did it do you and i guess that's kind of
how i viewed it and maybe we'll get into
that but
these things are so simple to say in a
certain way
to make sure that you're not trying to
make someone who has that same agenda as
you to feel stupid now when it is stupid
we call out stupid right when it's
[ __ ] stupidity it's racism it's
bigotry you goddamn right i'm gonna call
it out on the table
but
democrats have this way
of trying to paint something in a way
that no one wants to buy
and a perfect example
a perfect example is the election in
2022 in the primary against joe biden
bernie sanders a lot of people give me
all kinds of [ __ ] about this but bernie
sanders you mean 2020 yeah excuse me
2020 that but bernie sanders ran on uh
free healthcare and free college right
that was the thing
and joe biden said no but really
honestly both of them wanted the same
thing
they both wanted to make sure that
american people didn't go broke because
of a medical bill they wanted to make
sure that that americans aren't saddled
with a [ __ ] ton of debt now they may
have disagreed on how to do it but the
main thing that they disagreed on is how
the american people would buy their
message and the american people in
particular the democratic party spoke
and said no
we don't want you to say that you're
going to give away stuff that isn't free
because it's not free just because you
go get something at point of service and
you don't pay anything for it doesn't
mean someone or you aren't paying for it
yes and and that's why what pissed so
many people off about bernie sanders yes
is that is that
is that he wasn't he he had the message
right he we want what you're what you're
saying but we don't want to buy what
you're selling
right and i think the american people
not just [ __ ] trumpers
but people who are moderate who would
vote for a republican in one election
and a democrat in the other
if we could just speak to those people
we could make sure that we actually have
two parties in this country as opposed
to what we have right now which is only
one we only have one party in our
country right
i want to talk important for that tony
from the area that you come from and i
always talk to debbie about this and i
don't understand it because i always
feel
that i always say um one voice is noise
many voices together can be a movement
something i don't understand and you you
kind of alluded to it but never
understand this about our our people now
i'm obviously i'm a city guy pretty much
but
i've been to the i've been stationed in
rural areas when i was in the military
and i've had friends that lived in the
country so i i understand i didn't live
there but i've been there so i kind of
been around it one day i never
understand though and i'm talking as a
caucasian man
why is it in your opinion
that
poor
white people
can't get past their racism to get with
poor black people because they want the
same things like she just said
they wanna they want the american dream
they wanna try to
move up
but
i've seen
and especially the poor white people
that support trump
their racism and their hatred they would
never get together with african
americans and say you know what
we need to get past our this this racial
[ __ ] and we're all human beings and
let's come together collectively poor
people and make a movement
and
get out there and force politicians to
do things that are helping us because
though i despise trump as you know and
and you despise him too
his rhetoric though though he's totally
full of [ __ ]
resonated with a lot of poor and
uneducated people that voted for him
though i remind the viewers please don't
think it's every yahoo that's at his
rallies that that's his only base
because there's a lot of rich people
that hate his guts but like this tax
break that he eventually gave him that
are behind the scenes that won't come
out
of the shadows and say yeah i'm a trump
supporter they won't do it but why do
you why do you think as a caucasian man
coming from an area i'm not saying your
whole area is poor but from what you've
seen why oh no no it is okay okay and
that's that's that's that's the reason
why i mean that's the main racism
uh no no it's it's because they're poor
okay and the reason but here's but
there's a lot to unpack with that okay
um
and there's gonna be a lot of unpopular
opinions that i say here but the reason
why the reason why poor white folks and
rural white
there is there is no wealth in rural
areas right i mean there is there are
wealthy people compared to other people
in those areas right
the the problem that you have in rural
areas is this delusion that their white
privilege now they don't see it as white
privilege but their whiteness
is
is the thing that makes them wealthy
right because even inside poor white
areas that is the majority white and i'm
talking like 99.9
white
there is still classism right like
there's the people who live in the
[ __ ] trailer parks and there's the
poor folks that that live in the in the
hud housing and you know and there's the
druggies and the meth heads and the you
know and this and that well [ __ ] you
still have that [ __ ] where the where
there's people who have quote unquote
money in these areas
and and they're just as big of meth
heads and drug heads as the ones who
don't
but it's classism but they cling they
cling to this old notion that if
and it's racism but it's their poor
classism if we let
imagine this if we let black folks into
our community into our community
now what now what are we going to do now
now who's going to be who and who's
going to be what and
and it really is rooted into this the
white privilege um and it i mean it's
hard to even say and a lot of people are
like you're [ __ ] crazy but it's it's
tied to gun culture
it's tied to evangelical christianity it
absolutely is all all these all these
things and these fabrics are all tied
into each other and the one thing that
donald trump did and i i don't think a
lot of people understand exactly how he
did it nate you know all these political
analysts and all these
you know these people who think they're
[ __ ] smarter than everyone else out
there um try to break this down but
there's one thing that he did that no
one else would do
is he would hate the
people the way that they wanted him to
hate people yes
and give them the ability to do that
right like like donald trump isn't
necessarily anti-gay but he allows them
he allows them and gives them that space
to be anti-gay i actually i actually
don't think that donald trump has
convictions like he doesn't have any i
mean other than he's not he's other than
he's the best in the world right yes
yes he thinks he's the elite he thinks
he's the best that's the only conviction
that he actually has yes he's going to
throw anyone and everyone he can
underneath the [ __ ] proverbial bus to
try to save his ass even his children
definitely his children even ivanka he's
going to throw under the bus
to save his own ass yes
uh the next one to throw under the bus
is john eastman um that's the next one
to throw under the bus he's already done
rudy giuliani and michael cohen and the
list goes on and on right but
but as as as the the question of how did
donald trump
uh
hypnotize these real white people is
here's how
they all want to be rich they all think
they're going to be rich and really they
feel like they're rich they feel like
they're rich because they're wealthy
with white privilege when you grow up in
a white area and that's all there is is
white
that's it that's all there is is white
you have an abundance an abundance of
white privilege and that's all you have
in that area and that's your wealth
that's your wealth so the fear
the fear
of
people of color
black people hispanic people moving into
an area and stripping away your white
privilege your privilege to jobs and
your privilege to bank accounts and your
privilege to own businesses and all this
[ __ ] just absolute nonsense that has
nothing to do not a goddamn thing to do
with your whiteness um
that's what terrifies them and that's
what trump tapped into when he said
they're coming here they're taking jobs
they're criminals uh build a wall you
know
lock her up because that's another one
women they [ __ ] hate women they
[ __ ] hate women so i'll lock her up
was a perfect [ __ ] chant
and it just it really is a hundred
percent their fear that they're going to
lose
their white elixir whiteness yeah i
agree with you tony and you know what
because i always say this i say
you'll have poor white people to look
down on on poor black people
but you'll see
black people poor
and and i've seen it okay i've used to
hang out in the projects back in the day
you'll see uh older black woman back
then when i was in my uh 20s and uh
maybe six late 60s 70s who would bring
somebody in her house and put them at
their table baby you sit down and you
eat i'll feed you where a white person a
poor boy and i'm not and i don't wanna i
don't paint with broad strokes because
i'm not saying all but i'm saying some
where you won't see it the other way
you'll you'll see a black person doing a
black person
uh before
they uh before a poor black person would
do in a white person i've seen it
i don't understand it it's a shame
because i really wish
that
that group of people poor white people
poor black people will get together
because there's a lot of them out here
that are living below the poverty line
and i feel that they would be a strong
voice but i agree strong voices together
but i agree with you and what you said
and i like how you explain that next
question i want to ask you is
who is and put it out there maybe you'll
get it who is your dream guest to get on
your show that you would really love
because i know you you do more talk but
you do interviews as well if you could
get somebody that you and gabe would
love to have on who would it be just one
person that's all yeah and i know a
bunch of them but is it is it dead alive
or no no no no no that's later on oh
okay okay okay okay no i'm i'm in real
life that you can get on
the one the one person that i would like
to talk to rather it would be um
uh on a taped interview or not or just a
conversation um for an extended period
of time would be uh barack obama okay
okay
and and the reason why i say that isn't
because
i mean he is he was the president and um
i i believe he was a very good president
i think uh history is going to be much
more kinder to joe biden than it ever
will be to uh barack obama and the
reason why is because joe biden was
barack obama's vice president and he
came after he came after the biggest
[ __ ] disaster we've ever seen in
american politics so so history is going
to be very
very kind to joe biden um much kinder
than it probably will be to barack obama
because barack obama has his has his
faults even with his presidency um you
know every president does but um i i i
would like to more than anything more
than anything my curiosity um about
barack obama is
um
is about his race and what i mean by
that is
when does he feel white and when does he
feel black because he he did a great a
great speech um during the
2012 campaign our 2008 campaign excuse
me when jeremiah wright when fox news
sean hannity and russ i remember that
guy is reverend
reverend yeah reverend wright came out
and you know it was the the chickens
have come home to roost and they act
like he was some kind of racist and all
that kind of stuff and he was saying
extreme things but he was saying them
for a reason but barack obama had to
give a a speech on race and um that
and it always and i talk about this with
gabe on the show and even even
off off air
because gabe his dad is mexican and his
mother is white and you know he always
uh because i i don't have that
experience right like i i come from
i'm white right like they see me as
pasty white i don't they don't confuse
me this way that way or this way and
i've never been accused of not being
white enough or or whatever i mean i've
been accused of being a race trader
let's let's face it but but my
um
when someone grows up in that situation
where you know how do you navigate that
in life because that's not a life
experience that i have where a person
has to navigate not just not just one
race but two races and then from both
sides so that would be some of my
interest is
how did how did how did he work his way
through life in that situation because i
think it's a unique circumstance um
it's get becoming more and more um
prevalent but
and i think that's why it's so
interesting to
to see and i and i think until we get to
a place in our country where we can have
discussions uh real honest discussions
and barack obama can say honest things
about how he grew up and his the two
races that he is right
but yeah but you know what it is tony
he's biracial but you never heard them
say the first biracial president because
right mother is white his mother is
probably more like right exactly kansas
i think his mother's from cancer
and his father was from um
i don't know
kenya kenya okay from kenya but they
never said the first biracial they
always said black and you know as well
that the racists in this country never
saw that his mother was white i know his
mother died before he got elected oh
they were i think i think don't don't
you agree that there was probably and i
felt that during the the primary when it
was him and hillary clinton i felt like
there was a lot of this back and forth
that he's not black enough and i think
he probably got a lot of that right yeah
yeah he probably
yeah but you know what but you know what
that is that's a lot of racism because
i'll give you an example we it is a good
i'm glad you brought them good talking
for us this is why we do these shows
folks
which he just said he's not black enough
i can remember when i was in the
military now
i didn't know him personally i just saw
him one time come off of a plane during
the gulf war general colin powell and i
heard somebody say one time
he speaks so well and my [ __ ] head
wind explode i said oh you mean like you
mean like someone one of your colleagues
yeah yeah somebody right i'm like
first of all you're saying that because
it's a racist statement but first of all
take his color off of the thing he went
to some of the most prestigious colleges
in the most prestigious military schools
how the [ __ ] would you like him to talk
like flavor flav like put his hand down
his pants and play like yo yo yo i'm
like that's [ __ ] insulting he speaks
so well
but now if it's a white person because
you know black people get caught with
these these [ __ ] stereotypes that i
can't stand if a black person speaks
well they're trying to be white
no they're not maybe they went to maybe
they maybe and they don't have to even
be bi-racial maybe they maybe their
parents spoke the same way maybe that's
how they grew up in their household
maybe they went to prestigious schools
maybe they didn't come from a certain
area where people have a different
dialect i'm a new yorker it never left
me i say i you know i don't do dems and
does but i do have in my my cadence and
the way i talk the first thing i say is
new york and new jersey you know they
don't say kentucky they don't say they
know i'm not from indiana
right so you you have like you said he's
not black enough i hate that [ __ ] well
let me tell you something about dialect
and where i just come from is that when
y'all goes back to my hometown a lot of
times a lot of times brad when when i
goes back to my hometown i i get this
this little cadence that comes out of me
that wants to talks in a certain way and
i wants to do a certain thing and you
know
and that's and that's that's a good
point about um you know america in
general is that we're such a big country
and we are we are really diverse and yes
we are and we're getting more diverse
yeah right and and um i hate i hate that
um
that diversity is always is always like
a bad thing because i'll tell you
another story when i when i
got out of high school right before i
got married i had to take a job at a
factory because i needed
money that was the thing i needed and um
so i took a job like a second shift job
at a factory
and it was so weird because i'm such an
extrovert right
and it was one of the first times that i
had an experience where i was around
people that weren't completely that
weren't all white like
there were
there were people from africa that
worked at the factory jamaica um there
were people from poland uh mexico there
there was a lot of different diversity
in this factory the weirdest thing to me
and and i guess it's us as humans
is that i would go into the cafeteria
during lunch time and it it was
segregated now i don't mean like the the
factories segregated no they're still
about clicks
they self they self-segregate well
i wouldn't even call it clicks okay they
literally would segregate themselves
based on what their identity was right
whether it was a race or because there
was white people that sat together and
then there was country ass white people
that would sit together you know and
then and it just it i looked at it and
um one of my jamaican friends there at
the time uh he asked me one time because
i would go from table to table i'd sit
at a different table
every lunchtime every lunchtime that i
go and i'd sit at a different table
because i'd want to talk to different
people just like
and he said he said why
why do you change tables and sit with
different people in different groups
every time and i said man
i've hardly ever been out of missouri
let alone the country and i can come in
this cafeteria and i can sit at any
table and i can travel all around the
world by you telling me your experiences
where you're from
and i i said there no other place have i
ever been in my life that i could do
that and i'm going to take advantage of
that and you've seen these this light
bulb go off in his head and he's like
holy sh you know holy [ __ ] you're right
because that's the way i saw it is that
there the whole world is sitting in this
cafeteria and they're at such a
disadvantage because they don't realize
it right like they don't realize that
there's more to their
to to them than just them right like
like there's so much more you can learn
about culture and that has a lot to do
with the language like
there there are black people out there
that that you know speak well as they
would say but they also have a dialect
that is cultural to them rather they're
from whether they're from california or
los angeles whether they're from new
york i've had people from california
black people talk like surfers right
dude in a military you know just white
people who live down in the south in
louisiana and alabama right it doesn't
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean that we
have to um that culture is something to
embrace right exactly and great
something to embrace and and something
to
to figure out about other people um
and i i wish i wish we could come to a
place but i'm afraid that um
you know the thing that trump has proven
to us yeah yeah that there's still a lot
of racism in our country there is there
is i think until we move past some of
this generational institutional style
racism um until we move past that and i
don't know how long that could take or
should take or i mean i wish it was gone
now but i know um i don't think we're as
far as we thought we were because we
watched all these white people crawl out
underneath their rocks yeah and they're
willing they're willing to uh willfully
uh adopt delusion
just to hang on to their privilege and
it's really it's it's disappointing that
they think
that that their culture is at risk when
it's like no it's not at risk all
other cultures are trying to tell you is
that they want to be acknowledged just
like you are well tony you see me tony
how many times you see me tweet out
something and some people most people
because one thing i do like about it
twitter for the most part it kind of
puts clumps us together even though
there's some people on the left that i
want to [ __ ] choke the [ __ ] out of
but
for the most part you know we get
attacked but but it's it's small
segments of the larger picture of us
between now facebook is different but
you know i tweet out
all lives matter
only when black lives matter i'm not
talking about the movement i'm talking
about life's period if you want to
because you know they love to say
well all lives matter that's a given we
know all lives matter and they should
matter but until black lives matter till
you treat black people in this country
on par
for the people that want to say all
lives matter black lives don't matter
and they continuously prove that and
george floyd with that [ __ ]
derek shove and prove that i want to go
back to a talking point that you said
you know deb is from louisiana you
mentioned louisiana and i'm a new yorker
so you can imagine and you know debbie's
in african america so debbie will say
louisiana thing she'll be like hey babe
you want to go to the store yeah because
they answered she it's like they're not
and she's answer their own question and
me i talk a mile a minute so you put a
louisiana woman with a new york but we
found we found common ground and debbie
don't take [ __ ] so i can't really get
too much over on her but
you you when you were explaining what
you did
what breaks my heart honestly because
like you said i care so [ __ ] much
about humanity
what's so great about this country is
the diversity that you just said and i
can back that up with fact i've lived in
sicily i was in in cuba not i was on the
base you can't leave the base and go
into cuba because
and that was during castro fidel and i
lived in korea
we are small numbers in other people's
countries
but in this country as you well know
tony we are a true melting bowl and this
country was built on the back of
african-americans italian-americans
irish
uh uh spanish you name it we we had and
we have diversity still and that is
really our strength is our diversity but
the problem is like you said and we've
said before when we talked
that
racism
if you're gonna sit there and say and
i'm not saying you did but if you're
gonna say donald trump started racism
yeah you're [ __ ] delusional right it
was there but what donald trump 100 owns
is like you said he ripped the
[ __ ] rock open or the band-aid
off and now they all feel comfortable
but what's even more sad than just you
and me john q public is the
[ __ ] in the republican party
that do it on the senate floor on the
congress floor the [ __ ] marjorie
taylor greens and the ted cruz's and the
josh hawley's and and the paul gosser's
all these [ __ ] or louis
whatever his name is all of these
[ __ ] the racism that you saw
during kbj's confirmation
i have no problem with her questioning
about
rulings that she made but for lindsay
[ __ ] graham to talk about religion
and ted cruz to hold up a book about uh
critical race where the babies or
whatever
that had not a mother that was
grandstanding i think you put it on your
show or i think you did or somebody did
maybe it was gay put it out about how he
looked to see if he was [ __ ] trending
on twitter that's disgusting and that
type of [ __ ]
we even even with the strong thermos
racist [ __ ] that he was and
jesse helms [ __ ] we had robert byrd it
was a democrat that still was calling
people colored from west virginia you
remember robert byrd he would say color
[Music]
racist
i mean he was i think he converted i
think he was even part of the clan i
don't want to say 400 well he had some
decline was but he but he changed it but
he changed but you had but even with
their [ __ ] i just named you had
some decorum i know the left hates every
republican that ever lives since george
washington but the truth of the matter
is you still had decorum and you still
had some republicans that worked
together with democrats to make on bills
where they could or co-chair a co-chair
of committees where they could work
together like you said tony i'll end
this part on this
like you said there's only one party and
i'm and i'm i'm honest i want two
parties i don't want one party to have
everything because it's not it's not
good for the country to have one party
to have everything but right now you
have to vote blue because we only have
one party but i wish that we had
republicans and they're [ __ ] stupid
for one major reason they should have
dumped that [ __ ] trump they
should have been inclusive instead of
exclusive and they would have given
given the democrats a run we could have
debates on pro-life and pro-choice and
policies but if they if they would open
up their tent like they claim they do
they don't
they could have got more people under
their tent because as you mentioned
earlier you got conservative democrats
whether they want to admit that or not
that are closer to some republicans than
they are to the far the progressives in
our own party so even though i'm an
independent for the record but
i i agree with everything that you said
and i appreciate the way that you
explain things because you break it down
you don't use 500 words i try not to do
that on my show either because
like you said democrats will bring out a
laundry list of facts you lost the
person at the thing
messaging yeah they don't they don't
want to hear about you they don't want
to hear about this [ __ ]
defund the police you'll never hear me
say that i'm a back to blue guy but i
will back
decent police officers but i'm not a
blue line guy i'm not because i'm not
cover-up for a bad cop if you got a bad
cop you weed them out i'm for reforming
the police
because we need the police but this
whole you but you get you get a segment
of democratic party
let's get rid of police then who's going
to police the streets and and i think
you might have talked about it before on
your show or somebody i saw recently did
about community policing um that you you
got to have police men go back into
communities and build up because i don't
want to put everything on police
communities have to come together
community activists religious leaders if
they're really religious leaders need to
come together with the police and work
together to help their communities
especially in impoverished communities
where you need it more than any other
place probably in america and that's
white and black across the board
so
but you you talk about what i like to
and and you do what the midas touch does
do you call it and i try to do it on my
show you call balls and strikes you're
fair i you know i i wish i could say
something positive about the republican
party is the truth but but i can't right
now
good luck good luck yeah i know good
luck but but i am fair in this sense i
am fair in this sense
i gave credit to senator collins senator
matowski and senator romney
don't like them can't stand them to be
on the record to be fair but i do give
them credit that they did the right
thing and they voted for her to be a kbj
to be confirmed
i do give kenzer and cheney credit that
they acknowledge though they voted for
trump in 2020 and i will never forgive
him for that and i don't and i don't
really care for their politics liz
cheney 93 voted probably with trump
which i can't understand that i know
she's a true conservative but trump is
not a conservative
but they're doing the right thing now it
doesn't exonerate the other things that
they did does not but i i try to be fair
and say hey in this moment they're doing
the right thing
and you you have to do these things the
democrats no no no no no no yes yes yes
yes yes you have to be fair you ha in my
opinion you have to call it out okay
what i want to ask you is
you brought gabe in you had started your
show and then you brought gabe in which
to me it's a great um
mix you guys play off of each other very
well i've already said his tick tock
videos are top-notch and and you just
you gel you work well together so for
the viewers
explain a little bit about when you
brought uh gabe in and how you've
enjoyed the progression and the growing
that you guys have done together because
i saw some early shows and you can see
the progression where you guys are more
comfortable with each other you know you
know each other's roles and you play off
of each other and it really works well
and it doesn't know and that doesn't
always happen sometimes
you have a real strong personality and
somebody that may not be as strong and
that one always seems to you know go i
don't want to do the fist do you think
i'm doing josh harley
so explain that for the viewers
so so um before before i actually uh
brought
uh gabe to the show i would actually it
just was a an hour-long show on
wednesdays that i would do
and it was basically just an hour-long
rant which um it's pretty easy for me in
most cases you know i take two two or
three subjects and i can rant for about
three hours uh so i'd shorten it to an
hour on wednesdays and there was always
plenty of topics but i interviewed gabe
one time because i was trying to get
more and more people to interview um as
interest for um you know the viewers
because at that time i believe i was
doing the wednesday show and then i
would do my interviews i'd post those on
fridays right so like like i'd have my
normal show on wednesdays and then if i
did an interview i'd post it on a friday
and i i
i found gage videos hilarious and
brilliant
um not not just not just the the his
writing because his writing style is
very unique and it's hilarious because
gabe is a comedian yes maybe he's a
comedian um and he does commentary he
does political commentary but he is a
comedian probably first and he probably
would tell you that um but
i found his style really unique and i i
found him to be brilliant and not just
in again his writing because his writing
is unique and brilliant and how he does
his videos but his attention to detail
and that is not me like i'm a spaghetti
at the wall type guy
i don't i don't i don't like pre-plan a
lot of stuff like all the rants i do i
do not write those out that's all you
know that's all right off the top of my
head that's all you know just
real authentic me ranting
um he is a very prepared person he is
very prepared he's very organized um and
that's
not only not only do i need his
brilliance in comedy and editing and
graphics because he is a he's a
brilliant designer as well if you've
seen his videos and you see his
backgrounds you know some of the details
that he puts him is is
you know something i wouldn't even have
thought of um when he when he does this
stuff
um
and sometimes
um even after these months and months we
work together he still surprises me uh
but um but his attention the detail and
his organization was something that i
desperately needed for the show and um
and i knew i knew to make the show
successful and what i mean by success is
not just that it would you know like
make money or be with midas touch or
whatever um is that it could actually um
speak to somebody right it can move the
needle as i say that's all the phrase i
like to use i mean maybe not just move
the needle a lot i mean i hope we can
now move the needle a lot but maybe even
just a little bit maybe just with a few
people move that needle to realize that
that the messaging is off right um
whether they're a leftist or they're an
independent or they're a never trumper
or they're a trumper whatever maybe
um but he really helped bring
uh the ability for me to go to
more than just one time a week he gave
me the ability to
with his brilliant production design his
brilliant graphic design
make the show look more professional um
not look so damn cheesy um and uh you
know he's he's it's been a great success
and a big secret that maybe people don't
know out there is almost all of our
shows almost all of them are planned and
and
designed and produced inside of a
twitter dm which is kind of a
it's kind of a crazy thing to think so
because that's how like i've never met
gabe in person right like we've never
been standing next to each other so it
did take a little bit for us to get used
to each other um on the show but uh we
you know off air meetings and stuff like
that uh we've been able to uh we've been
able to find our stride and i think
it'll get better and better as time goes
along and as we as add more aspects into
the show
and uh um you know
our audience loves bonehead of the week
and that's kind of that's kind of uh if
you want to know that's the brainchild
of gabe sanchez the bonehead of the week
so
um you know things like that and then
um you know little things like we had
this video recently that we did with
jojo from uh jurors she actually wrote a
tweet about the trucker convoy
and i got this idea in my head i'm like
oh my god i hear like a
a civil war
ken burns type document hilarious i
thought
and so i sent her a message uh and it
was just me
reading her tweet in that voice and
she's like oh my god so she wrote
another one
and then she sent it and i'm like hey we
have to send this to gabe to see if he
can make a video so he took our you know
joe was the brilliance behind the
writing and then i did the voice and she
did her voice and we sent those two
audio files to gabe and he came up with
uh the letters from a trucker's convoy
which is hilarious
you go to our if you go to my youtube
page just type just search the tony
michaels podcast i i think i have it set
as the very first the top video like the
preview or whatever it is at the top you
can watch the original one and there's
two of them but that one is um that
one's hilarious so that
that
that shows you
the brilliance of gabe sanchez when you
can just say gabe i've got this idea
here's my thoughts and then he somehow
he cranks it out and makes it happen
cool
all right let's segue into the second
half
it's the random fun stuff this is what
people really really want to hear yeah
okay what's tony's favorites and so on
yeah let's go with it favorite
genre of movies
favorite genre of movies probably uh
like historical fictions i really like
those like
if you've seen in glorious bastards
that's that's a really good movie um
there was one that came out i think this
year last year's uh
king kingsman or something like that but
it was kind of a historical fiction
um i like i like stuff that's set in
real history but it's not it's not
exactly
real um so i would say historical
fiction and then documentaries is like a
really close second okay
what's the movie that you can sit and
watch a hundred times and never back to
the future back to the future you know
that that's that's my favorite movie
back to the future um i have the whole
[ __ ] thing memorized okay
who's your favorite
or one or two actors that if something
comes out you gotta see it um
you know that's that's a good question i
mean there's a lot of good ones out
there
um
probably one that i like to watch the
most and i don't even know if i'd call
him my favorite but almost everything he
is in
he does a brilliant job as tom hardy
um tom hardy mm-hmm yeah yeah but uh
some of my some of my favorites
obviously are like
you know tom hanks um will smith used to
be no i'm just kidding
well i mean will smith was you know he
was a good actor he had good movies uh
he played he played this guy you know
um
and he had he had some good movies and
he he kind of ruined it so but uh no
there's a lot of there's a lot of good
movies a lot of good actors out there
and they come and they go but there's
always the the mainstays and i i would
say probably some of my other favorite
movies
with an actor that you have to see a
movie
in the two guys is morgan freeman and
samuel on jackson like they're in so
many movies and every movie they're in
like they're not going to do a movie
that's not good right even snakes on a
plane because it has samuel jackson in
it is a [ __ ] good movie so
i don't know about that but i love it
well you know some good art some could
argue something yeah yeah you you
stretching it there right i do love
samuel yeah i agree with that i just saw
him in a movie devin and i watched the
other night called the cleaner did you
see that
no i haven't check it out it was on
netflix the cleaner that came out i
think it might have been 17 either 2007
or 2017. really remember yeah i
rewatched i rewatched um the negotiator
was saying oh that was good yeah it's
like an early and early you know um
jackson movie where he was one of the
big stars in there you know and um so
that that's a a really cool movie then i
think i watched that a couple weeks ago
okay flip it actress
actress um
oh wow
actress i would you know
um
there's so many there's so many good
ones out there jennifer lawrence is
fantastic
[ __ ] just absolutely
absolutely brilliant absolutely
brilliant jennifer lawrence um you've
seen american hustle
it's it's fantastic um but the the most
recent one the one she's in with
leonardo dicaprio um that don't look up
you know we're halfway through it don't
don't don't no spoilers no but
through it it's it's so
she does such a great job and they give
her such a shitty [ __ ] haircut i know
it just
um she's probably
i mean she's she's super brilliant
jennifer lawrence can probably play just
about um
anything she just is she's just that
good so okay
favorite musical band
favorite band um so probably it's not
really i mean i guess it's a band
but um
i grew up on uh old country country gold
so okay uh one one of my favorite voices
of all time is is george jones i love
him believe it or not believe it or not
i love him
yeah so that's uh you know and i i like
all the you know um the old old country
uh voices randy travis is another great
voice forever and forever amen
yeah
yeah yeah you know he's uh
i forget what award ceremony was but
then he actually he did the he did the
last uh the amen on the forever and ever
amen okay
most memorable concert you've ever been
to
the most memorable concert i've ever
been to this is this is going to sound
really weird because i think it was the
first concert i ever been to
um and it was a big deal when i was a
kid but there was this christian rock
guy named carmen or something like that
and he used to have the dark black hair
maybe i don't remember talking about
just remember my aunt took me and my
cousins
um they took us to columbia
to the university of missouri i know
you're talking about it yeah which is
that the the
the stadium are the the the place now
it's still there it's the hern center
but at the time it's where all the
basketball
teams played stuff and they were chat to
hearn center and when we went in you
know i saw a little kid so it was so big
and so you know there was lights and
everything so
that is unfortunately unfortunately
probably my most memorable because it
sticks out in my memory so much
i say unfortunately because
i don't remember the songs i don't you
know i just it just stands out in my
mind okay the most memorable probably
because i was such a little kid i think
i know you're talking about it because i
think i know somebody that knew him
um and if if this the guy i'm thinking
about he's got like the dark dark black
black jet you know dyed hair it might it
might be but but he was really like um
he was he was a christian rock but he
was yeah i think it's him he was like
really leaking into the mainstream you
know i think it is him okay
favorite
noise or sound
favorite noise or sound uh well you know
i'm kind of a funny guy i like to laugh
and uh so
unfortunately i'd have to say farts are
funny so he's gonna go there
i i just i can't i can't help it um i
think i think i i'd have to go back and
look but i think our boy scaramucci said
the sounds of his farts i think that's
what he is is that is that what anthony
said might have said i think he said
that i think i i like to laugh and and
um i certainly you know for all the
folks out there listening i definitely
100 almost all the time laugh at my own
farts right so well jim pettick was the
best in show he was the guy that played
opposite fred willard at the table right
i think he's i think he said farts too
yeah i mean they're they're funny they
you just don't have a situation i mean
you could be really depressed really you
know down and out and hear a really good
fart and it'll make you chuckles okay
i'll take you at your word yeah all
right
least flip it least favorite sound of
noise
um least favorite sound or noise oh man
i i hate
and i and this sounds bad but i hate a
yappy dog like
it just it drives me nuts like we we
have a dog and a lot of times i don't
know if
anyone know this but i have a chair that
sits in front of my desk here and my dog
now he's not a yappy dog he can be
sometimes but he lays in front of it and
sometimes he snores
if you hear this if you hear this sound
like someone snoring in the background
it actually is my dog snoring dantino
does that too yeah but but every once in
a while he gets a little yappy and it it
just
it drives me crazy when he when he gets
yappy and barky i guess maybe it reminds
me of trump you
know no i don't compare the dog that's
true
this little this little dog who thinks
he's big and bad and
he's really not he's just he's all he's
all barkies that's hilarious okay
favorite food
favorite food
man i'd have to i'd have to really
oh it's a toss-up between um
hamburgers and pizza i'm you know i'm an
american kid so
okay i would say i would say pizza
though probably okay how are you capping
it off with what are you having for
dessert
what am i having for dessert after pizza
um or whatever favorite dessert if i if
i had to choose um between chocolate
cake and strawberry shortcake it'd be
very difficult but i would probably
probably choose the strawberry shortcake
you know get the shortcake you put the
strawberries on the whipped cream on top
yeah so okay
if you hit the lottery tomorrow 200 300
400 million oh baby that's a lot of
money yep what's the first thing you're
going to do
i'm going to keep doing what i'm doing
that's the first thing i'm going to do
just keep doing what i'm doing and then
maybe probably probably um
probably buy my wife a convertible or
something and maybe a lake house and she
wants a house on a lake somewhere so
maybe do that but but i just do the same
thing i'm doing now probably wouldn't be
my it might look a little different i
mean
it might look a little different in the
background here but i just buy a studio
put yourself in the studio yeah either
then i'd build one you know somewhere
and build one out
to make make the studio the way i wanted
it as opposed to the way i have it but
um yeah that wouldn't change much okay
do you have a hobby
do i have a hobby i'm you're looking at
it my hobby turned into what i'm doing
um
i've always loved the talk i've always
been good at it i get it from my mother
she can talk for hours and hours and
hours about yeah endlessly almost about
nothing you know
i can carry on a conversation and
communicate with someone so okay so
that's always been um it's always
probably been the thing that i love the
most is talking we've talked on the
phone a lot and i always get the sense
when i'm on the phone with someone
they're like jesus is he ever gonna shut
the [ __ ] up good lord
but uh no i am i'm really good at
talking so okay my hobby is and and
maybe that's a good thing maybe it's a
good thing that i'm doing yeah we're
using your voice so it is a good thing
yeah sure all right so i'm dropping i
got two new questions in this part yeah
sure just in case you practice i was
gonna throw you off on this no no no i
didn't practice at all i don't prepare
for anything
what is your number one thing
on your bucket list
the number one thing on my bucket list
oh boy i don't have a huge bucket list
um
but you know i i probably i probably
want to uh
i probably want to go to europe and
travel around europe
[Music]
and just see
see
with my own two eyes
some of europe and the history in europe
and really around the world but europe
interests me the most because i
i really i've really studied hard and
watched a lot of documentaries on the
second world war and fascism how it took
over in
germany and italy and um because i see
so many similarities now with the
the republican party and these pedo cons
these people who are projecting and and
it's um it really is kind of scary the
similarities
um
so i would like to go there and
not only see some of the good parts but
see some of the atrocities for my own
two eyes um so okay
if you could meet one person
from any time in history dead or alive
any walk of life
who would you like to meet and what
would either be your first question
or a couple things you'd like to talk
about
anyone anytime anywhere dead or alive
that that is uh that's a really tough
question because there's a lot of people
um that i'd like to sit down and have a
conversation with um
you know
probably um
the reason why we are the country that
we are today is
franklin delano roosevelt turned the
presidency
really into the type of office that it
is now
and um
because of the situation that the
country was in and how he really
he really was able to draw the people
together and i don't think a lot of
people realize this like a lot of white
rural people they're like oh socialism
bad and socialist and a bunch of
socialism sucks and it's going to ruin
our country and all this [ __ ] what they
don't understand is their grandpappy's
grandpappy loved franklin dylan
elizabeth and they they the american
farmer the american farmer with the farm
bill that passed under fdr are the first
[ __ ] socialists that we had in this
country so the reason why you had the
privilege that you have rural white
america the reason why you live and you
think you're so wealthy because you have
inherited as poor as you are you have
inherited all the wealth of your
poorness
the reason why that is the reason why
is because your [ __ ] ancestors your
grandpappy was a goddamn socialist
farmer and they loved fdr so they're
probably the one person that i would
want to go talk to because i'd have a
lot of questions for him too because i'd
want him to answer for the for the
internment camps that he did
um
yeah asian people in this country and um
so i'd want him to ask that question
absolutely
uh the other the other question i'd want
to ask him is when when did he really
see hitler as a threat when did he see
fascism as the thing that could destroy
democracies right it would probably if i
could only choose one and one only
because it's a long list i'd i love to
have conversations with a lot of people
but
um that would be the one you know and
you know this because your history guy
how many times was he president he died
his last presidency how many times right
more than two he was a president yeah
more than 20. so so
if the rural farmers didn't like him he
was winning so somebody was voting for
him he was winning all these damn times
right i mean the reason why the reason
why uh we have two-term presidents is
because of fdr because they were scared
of yeah of monarch type dynasties that
would
that would rule over our country um
which is some of the argument that
people used against like hillary clinton
and um i'm sure that they'll use against
other people that are related to you
know like jeb bush or whatever yeah they
used it against george bush because you
know he was george h.w bush's son right
um so this monarchy type dynasty rule
this uh platocracy i guess you call it
um
so you know they really got afraid of
that so they put two terms in for a
present which you know rather that
rather that bears out in history like
over a long period of time because it's
only been 100 years since you know not
even 100 years since we've been doing
that so it's hard to tell if that if two
terms is the correct is the correct
amount of terms um i think it's it
probably is in my opinion because it's
just enough to get to make progress but
not enough to [ __ ] everything up right
can you imagine if trump got in again oh
my god okay with everything we talked
about today tony if you ever sum
yourself up in a few thoughts
as a human being what would you say
um that's a good question i think um
i think if i had to evaluate myself i'd
say that i'm i'm very imperfect but i
try to be provocative provocative in a
way to get people's attention
to make sure
that people understand that our country
the design of it
is life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness like that's the whole design
and liberty
is the key ingredient
and so many people get freedoms and
rights [ __ ] up in their head
um you know they think their freedom is
to go to the grocery store and they got
the freedom to pick 12 different types
of frozen pizza like that's not your
[ __ ] freedom folks that's capitalism
that's just that's just one company
making 12 different products to make you
think you got the freedom to pick what
between 12 different frozen pizzas you
dumb [ __ ] so if i can use my
provocative voice and the way that i say
things
and a language maybe
even a dialect or a way of saying things
are a way to convey a message to
communicate
that our liberty is more important to us
than anything else that that there is
the only thing that we have
that will keep our democracy is our
liberty and if you lut if you let
someone oppress the rights of other
people and take away their liberty they
will [ __ ] come for yours
and they will cut and they will come
fast and and in a hurry i mean we've
seen it just in the last few weeks where
republicans state legislators all around
the country are passing bills to
get rid of age limits for marriage
these [ __ ] people want to marry
children and they're sexualizing our
kids gender and they're projecting that
[ __ ] onto people who just want people to
have liberty gay people don't want to
talk about being gay in kindergarten
they just want to be human beings
exactly they want to be treated with
dignity they want to be treated with
humanity they want to have [ __ ]
liberty to be the person that they
[ __ ] are and so many times in this
country we get people
who confuse rights and freedoms with
liberty the rights and the freedoms that
we have
that is the vehicle that we use to get
our liberty the freedom and i say this
it's in my show's intro the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not
liberty and i think if we could live by
that and that is what i try to do is use
my provocative voice if you want to call
it that my i'm a provocateur a
commentator that if i can convince
enough people that the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty if i can do that in my
lifetime however much i got left if i
can just do that then i have moved the
needle
um that that's probably
summing me up i i hope that that's what
i live up to
that from here on out as imperfect as i
may be
if i can do that just convince people
that the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not liberty and
liberty is what we strive for then i
think i've done my job so okay
and final question of the show
if you have a saying
that you live your life by what is it
i know you just said it right
just that yeah it's the freedom the
freedom to oppress the the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty
um you know
again growing up my mom worked in the
state capitol and she worked in a budget
office so she saw the politics of it
because they had to score every single
bill
so my mom would
would talk a lot of politics in her
house because she was entrenched in it
every single day
and the politics of old is not the
politics of new
and that really is what i mean by
that there's only one party we have a
two-party system
and it's not just it's not just a
two-party system in our federal
government um most of our state
governments are two-party system most of
our local
county governments are two-party type
systems
you know some of the school boards and
some of those other small local
elections they're not really two-party
but they are
and if we don't really have two parties
who are
who
actually their ultimate goal is for
democracy and for the people to have
their voice
and for liberty
if they're not then we do not have two
[ __ ] parties there is one party in
this country that wants to destroy our
democracy they want to destroy it and
that's not an american party they're not
anymore no they're [ __ ] fascists they
want to tear down our government they
want to take away our constitution they
want to take they want to take away
your consent for for your of your child
to marry someone that's what's next
they're right around the corner they are
they are they are indicting and charging
a woman in texas for murder for having a
medical procedure
that is where we're at everyone's like
oh you're you're so oh my gosh you're
you're losing your mind you're you're
you're you're out of touch you're being
so extra about it
listen
when they start to take away your
liberty and they find out how [ __ ]
easy it is to take away this person's
liberty take away this group's liberty
take away people in this state's liberty
and then this state and then that state
in this state in this state you don't
think you don't think they're coming for
you
exactly
so i would say i would say my phrase
is the
the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people
is not
liberty you do not have the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people it
doesn't matter their religion doesn't
matter your religion it doesn't matter
their race it doesn't matter your race
it doesn't [ __ ] matter in this
country under our constitution under our
democracy
and under our constitutional democratic
republic if they want to call it that
they do not have the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people they just
don't you need to put it on a shirt you
need you need to have shirts for your
viewers yeah i've got some art that i've
made that i should put on t-shirts but
i'm i'm not good at the merch thing
right yeah i mean i'm okay yeah yeah you
got the massage bros behind you they're
good stuff yeah well you know i'm i'm
just not as good at that i i like to
talk about politics and i have to talk
about merge but i'm trying to get better
i'm trying to well you know what you
said you know the clip that you played
when you had me on your show my dad said
the same thing if you allow them to take
come take away your rights then you
ain't gonna understand when you come and
think we're yours because they're coming
for yours and then gabe talked about or
you talked about uh gabriel union
talking about them coming for lgbtq
rights well if they're coming if they
take theirs who do you think is next
nobody saw and but you know what but
it's and we'll uh close out
um it's funny how the republicans always
talk about hillary's coming for your
guns and obama's coming for your guns
they're always screaming about coming
for they're coming for this and they're
coming in and no one ever came for [ __ ]
like they claim but they're the
[ __ ] that are actually coming
for your [ __ ] but they do that little
trump thing they give you a little
silver thing they get you know they make
you look over here and then they're over
there doing what they're really doing
and trump did it all the time i want you
to give all of your social media
platforms for the viewers
yeah so if you want you just uh anywhere
you want to search you can go to google
youtube
twitter wherever you want to go just
search the tony michaels or the tony
michaels podcast
you can find us on twitter
at me personally at the tony michaels or
at tonymichaelspod but just go to
thetonymichaels.com
thetonymichaels.com and all the links
are there even even speaking of merch
even my merch store and gabe's merch
stores
on there if you want to go get a bobo
the clown he's got a great t-shirt as
bobo the clown um so go visit
thetonymichaels.com
all the social media links are there
instagram and all that kind of good
stuff watch us
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central on youtube twitter twitch you
can go to our
our youtube page the tony michaels
podcast just search it on youtube and
you can find it subscribe there um and
now we're actually broadcasting from the
midas touch facebook page because we are
partnering with might as touch so you
can find us on facebook our show on mind
as such as facebook page and you can
follow me on facebook i i do more stuff
on instagram but um you can follow me on
facebook if you want you'll see my
instagram stuff i push it over to to
facebook so you'll see on my instagram
post there okay i'm gonna close out with
a couple of thoughts and then give you
back yeah sure so
you already know where where i stand
about moving humanity forward you know i
told you when i did your show you and
gabe are doing the same thing we do it
at a personal cost sometimes but i don't
care because this is this is where i'm
at
we need to keep moving humanity forward
you're doing it through your show you're
doing a different style that i'm doing
but it's how it but it hits a different
audience and some of it is crossover
all of us have to work together to do
this thing you found your niche i found
my niche and whatever works to move
humanity forward that's what we need to
do
you know you have my strong endorsement
of your show you guys you guys are doing
it you're putting it out there you're
making people think that's what i try to
do with my show my interviews i'm
talking to people and let them let them
talk because they was like well you know
you're pretty good about letting me yeah
i let people go on and talk because i
want your thoughts it's not it's not me
interviewing me it's me interviewing you
i want
different perspectives of people that
make sense because we need to be out
there
in the atmosphere because like you said
tony you nailed it there's so much right
wing crazy [ __ ] out there that we gotta
push back and we gotta push back every
single [ __ ] day whether it's on your
platform whether it's on your shows
wherever it may be so i appreciate what
you're doing i see what you're doing i
you definitely deserve to be picked up i
told you this before on the midas touch
network i hope you blow up i hope you i
hope you blow cnn and msnbc and all of
them out the water because i'm getting
tired of mainstream and the games that
they're playing so i'm glad that we have
the opportunities that we do to do it
the way we want to do it right we're not
we're not beholden to you know we want
to make this money we want to do this
sure money helps to produce our shows
and we can make the quality better if we
get a student all that great but we
still are putting out what we want to
put out and nobody's telling us what the
[ __ ] to say and that's my goal on my
show no one's going to tell me what to
say and mainstream networks are they're
they're emboldened
the advertisers and money and all this
stuff and it's watering down a lot of
things that they're doing so what i want
to do now is give you back the mic and
whatever you want to close out with
well i i'll just have to say i
appreciate you coming on my show and
it's been a blast coming on your show
and i hope you come back on our show and
i i certainly will come back here so um
i always i always like to talk this
stuff out i always like to to
give people a chance to listen maybe to
a different perspective like you said um
but to you know maybe a perspective that
they haven't heard before on the left
and that that's that's really
probably the thing that i heard most the
comments that i heard most about my tick
tock videos is like god you sound like
when you first started i thought you
were going to say trump [ __ ]
you know they they thought they were on
a trump
supporter video and then this stuff came
out of my mouth and they're like whoa
it's the exact opposite of what i
thought sometimes they they would even
be confused they're like ah this is not
real this person's like pretending or
doing satire i'm like no it's
i [ __ ] believe wholeheartedly in this
stuff
so um i appreciate you having me on on
the show i really do so
and move humanity forward and and also
[ __ ] them
i just want to get that out that's right
i was gonna say i thought you were gonna
hold up the hat you know [ __ ] them oh
well i got i got the heads in the
background here okay yeah yeah there you
go
yeah
the [ __ ] i'm you know
one last thing is um
you say it at the end of the tick tock
videos
and it wasn't like intentional like i
didn't i didn't know i was going to
become the [ __ ] guy i
really wasn't playing i just would say
that at the end of the video because
it's like a perfect protest term like
[ __ ] them right [ __ ] them but you know
if anything pisses you off and you know
it's not right or whatever [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them you know and so i say it at
the end of the videos what i discovered
is there's a couple videos that i did
that were a little different style and i
wouldn't say it and people like wait a
second
you didn't say [ __ ] them at the you know
they kind of get pissed off at me i'm
like oh okay well i guess i am the
[ __ ] guy if they get mad especially
when i don't say it so that's okay it's
my [ __ ] [ __ ] there you go
all right brother on that note on the on
the [ __ ] note
uh it's been great having you on it and
again i appreciate it tony and we will
be in touch and you know always like i
do come on anytime brother yep we'll
talk to you soon brad all right take
care
hey folks that's another episode of the
bad brad burke with show on the ringside
report web tv channel now make sure you
follow me on twitter at
bad bread rsr against at bad bread rsr
and check out my great writing team on
ringsidereport.com
well my brother from another mother tony
michaels i know he would bring it he's
got knowledge he's doing it in his way
which i respect it's a different
approach and i like it because he puts
it out there and the way that a lot of
people understand it and never get uh
tied up around either one of us cursing
hey i'm a new yorker he's from missouri
we curse a lot but there's a message
there there's a message there and
sometimes the cursing
is to add emphasis but a lot of times
the curse is because we're so passionate
about what we're talking about all right
so follow him and his co-host gabe
sanchez on the tony michael's pod on the
midas touch
network all right folks again if you're
new hit the subscribe button leave your
comments below i greatly appreciate it
to all my new subscribers i picked up
several from uh the sherry jacobs show
that i did a couple days ago thank you i
welcome you to my channel let's tweet
this out let's retweet this out let's
make this go viral tony and gabe show
deserve it all right
and on that note
every act of kindness
is a little love
we leave behind
bad bread out thank you for watching the
bad brad birkwood show please follow
subscribe leave comments forget about it
and move humanity forward
[Music]
you